The patient appears Anemic and pale, period.
Patient's heart rate is 98 and blood pressure is 120/80, period.
Go to history of the present illness.
The patient presents with severe pain and swelling in
the left knee due to micro-tears in the patella tendon, period.
And just to show you a little bit about what's going on the background.
So, we're taking the statement and running it through
computational linguistics to extract out all the key data points.
Then we have mapped that to an in-memory graph.
The graph contains a hybrid of
20 different clinical ontologies that we
have woven together and then made it computable and processable.
And that's actually how we perform all of
our clinical decision support matching to clinical models.
Because at the end of the day, we're not saving the statement in the medical record.
We're saving the IDs using FHIR. So, clear this out.
Because that allows us to do things like ICD 10 coding.
So, this is not enough specificity to come up with
a fully refined ICD 10 building code. So, we're going to prompt.
Only swelling. It's traumatic.
And this is the initial count.
So, here's all our ICD 10 codes.
Here is the structures that we are going to be
saving using FHIR into the electronic medical record.
And over here on the left, this is the statement that
we're going to throw away. I'll do a few more.
Acetaminophen, 500 mg. Twice a day for two weeks with food as needed for pain, period.
The patient needs a bilateral mammography, period.
Now, as you noticed,
we're actually determining where in the medical record that each bit of
information goes based on the information that we extract out from it.
Go to review of systems.
The patient's breath sounds a normal, period.
The patient's heart sounds are normal, period.
So here, it's determining body system,
again, by the information that we extract out of the statement.
The patient's grandmother died of lung cancer 10 years ago, period.
The patient had an appendectomy four years ago, period.
So here, this is going in
the medical record for this patient but it's
going in as information about their grandmother.
In other words, the patient isn't dead the grandmother is dead.
Effectively, once you have information about each statement,
so many things about the capture of clinical information can be automated,
including clinical decision support in real time,
in figuring out where to place things in a medical record.
At the end of the day, the goal is to put
the clinicians attention back on
the patient and away from having to serve the needs of the system.
Anyway, thanks for watching this demo.